this is a fox news alert we promised to
monitor the ongoing trump rally
mississippi for some news and we have
some the president advised that brett
kavanaugh
addressed rather the brett kavanaugh
confirmation about five minutes ago we
spoke about christine ford
nbc and the creepy porn lawyer at the
center of a lot of this here's what he
said
how did you get home i don't remember
how did you get there i don't remember
where is the place i don't remember
how many years ago was it i don't know i
don't know
i don't know i don't know
what neighborhood was it in i don't know
where's the house i don't know
upstairs downstairs where was it i don't
know but i had one beer that's the only
thing i remember
and a man's life is in tatters a man's
life is shattered
we had another woman just reported by a
sleazebag
lawyer named abiate sleazeback
sleazeback we have
well it turned out even nbc was as bad
as they got
even nbc couldn't shield her with that
interview did you see that incident
this woman had no clue what was going on
that was president just minutes ago
we'll continue to monitor the rally if
more news emerges